[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I'm excited
to introduce our guests
and share a little bit more
about the National Asian
American Survey.
So the National Asian
American Survey, or NAAS,
is a scientific and
nonpartisan effort
to poll the opinions
of Asian Americans
and Pacific Islanders on
issues such as public policy,
political preferences,
experiences
with discrimination,
and race relations.
And here with us
today we have two
of the principal
investigators and researchers
from the NAAS, Jennifer Lee
and Karthick Ramakrishnan.
Jennifer Lee is a
professor of sociology
at Columbia University.
She has written award-winning
articles and books, including
"The Asian American Achievement
Paradox," "The Diversity
Paradox," "Asian American
Youth," and "Civility
in the City."
Committed to public
engagement, she
has written for
and been featured
in a variety of media outlets,
including "The New York
Times," "The San Francisco
Chronicle," CNN, and NPR.
And then Karthick Ramakrishnan
is an associate dean
of the UC Riverside
School of Public Policy
and professor of public
policy and political science.
And he directs the National
Asian American Survey
and is the founder
of AAPIData.com,
which features demographic
data and policy
research on Asian Americans
and Pacific Islanders.
He's also written
dozens of op-eds
and appeared in over
1,000 news stories
in many, many major
outlets, including "The New
York Times," "The Economist,"
"Los Angeles Times," and CNN.
So please welcome Jennifer
and Karthick to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN:
Thank you, Amy,
and thank you everyone
for being here,
both in person and remotely.
There's a lot of ground that
we're going to cover today.
We'll have plenty of time
for question and answers.
I'll be presenting primarily
on AAPI Data, which
as Amy mentioned, is a site that
seeks to make data and policy
research on Asian Americans
and Pacific Islanders more
accessible.
What we found in
the last four years
is that we've had
tremendous influence
in terms of raising the
media profile and awareness
among journalists
of not only, kind
of, general facts about
Asian Americans and Pacific
Islanders, but also
some of the complexity
that we'll go over today.
Jennifer will
primarily be presenting
from our latest National
Asian American survey,
and then I'll conclude with
some final data points.
So, first of all,
just in the future,
if you're interested
in finding out more,
please take a look
at our website.
We have a lot there.
We have infographics.
We do a fair amount of work
through our infographics.
We also have a feature called
Quick Stats which gives people
access to data at various levels
of geography on frequently
requested tables from
the Census Bureau.
Given all the talent
in the room here,
I'd love to talk
later about maybe ways
that we can improve some
of our Quick Stats features
with the talent among
folks at Google.
The main takeaways of
my portion of the talk
is, first of all, to talk about
the growing importance of Asian
Americans, but to show that
that growth in and of itself
is limited, because there
is a big gap between what
our numbers look
like and where we
stand in terms of leadership
and civic engagement.
And I'll submit to you that
the problems of leadership
and mobility within
the corporate structure
is related to our
lack of visibility
when it comes to
civic engagement.
And the solutions
are linked as well.
So first of all, in terms
of talking about the growing
importance of Asian
Americans, some of you
may be familiar with some
of these statistics already.
First is population growth.
Whenever someone talks about
why we need to pay attention
to Asian Americans
and Pacific Islanders,
we are among the fastest growing
racial groups in the country.
This was true from 2000 to 2010,
and it's been true since 2010
as well.
And much of this growth
is fueled by immigration.
So what we've seen since
2004, so over a decade, almost
a decade and a half
now, there have
been more Asians
that are coming in
as legal permanent
residents than Latinos
coming in as legal
permanent residents.
Starting in 2007,
a decade ago, there
have been more Asian foreign
born coming into the United
States than from any
other region in the world,
including Mexico
and Central America.
We've also seen a rapid increase
in the Asian undocumented
population.
One of the things you may have
seen, this little factoid,
that one out of every
seven Asian immigrants
is undocumented.
That's something
that we had done
a lot of information work--
we produced
infographics and I've
done a lot of social
media engagement on that.
So much so that that
talking point is now
entering into the
discourse in Congress
among leaders in the
Congressional APA Caucus.
And then finally, it might
not be surprising at all
to folks in Silicon Valley,
that Asian Americans are very
dominant in the H-1B
visa category, which
is very much in the news
today in terms of what
the future of high-skilled
immigration to the United
States will look like.
And it's not just
Silicon Valley.
When the travel ban first went
into place, not only Google,
Apple, Microsoft, and
many tech companies
had a very strong reaction.
Because it would not only
disrupt their business,
but also went
against the, kind of,
core values of what
inclusion meant
within these
corporate structures.
But you also saw universities
speaking up in ways
that they had never spoken
before, and quickly.
Because that also struck at
the core of PhD programs,
post-doctoral fellowships,
and employment,
and in professorships, and
other research positions.
Medicine, too, has been
very strongly affected
by the kind of
immigration changes.
Not only in terms of
proposed legal changes,
but executive actions
that have happened
in the last few months.
So, needless to say,
we are now recognizing
that Asians are an important
part of the immigration story.
Although when it comes to
undocumented immigration,
most people still don't
think of Asian Americans
within their general conception
of who the undocumented are.
Please go to our website.
We have a portion on
undocumented immigration, which
has some of these
numbers in various states
and also by national origin.
Asian Americans are
also an increasing share
of the foreign born.
So even though we've had more
Asians than Latinos coming in,
in terms of inflows, the
base population of who
the foreign born, or who
the immigrant population is,
is still close to
a majority Latino.
But that's going to change.
And by 2055, there'll
be more Asian immigrants
in the United States than
Latino immigrants in the United
States.
And Asian Americans are
also an important part
of the immigrant vote.
This is something
that I try as often
as I can when I
speak to journalists,
but even elected officials.
Most people when they think of
immigrant voters think Latinos.
I can't tell you the number
of times in which people make
that easy assumption and
switch between saying
Latino and immigrant.
But, in fact, most Latinos
in the United States,
no matter how you
measure them in terms
of the resident population,
in terms of the adult citizen
population, in terms of the
registered voter population,
they are nowhere close to a
majority immigrant, right?
Depending on the numbers,
you're talking about 2/3
of the Latino population
as native born.
By contrast, Asian Americans
are a predominantly immigrant
population.
So I keep saying, when
you talk about immigrants,
you have to think about Asians.
Then people say, well,
but the Asian population
is much smaller, right?
So maybe it still
makes sense when
you talk about the
composition of immigrants
and immigrant voters to talk
about them as predominantly
Latino.
But even there the numbers show
a very different story, right?
What we see at
the national level
and in states like-- and
in states like California,
it's actually-- you have
more Asian immigrant voters
than Latino voters.
What you find is there are about
as many Asian immigrant voters
as Latino immigrant voters.
So if someone's going to be
intellectually honest and talk
about the immigrant vote,
they cannot just talk about
the Latino vote.
By the way, there's
a decent number
of white immigrant voters
nationally as well.
About a quarter of the
immigrant population
that is registered to vote
is non-Hispanic white.
What you'll see as a continuing
theme in this presentation
is that we need to go
beyond stereotypes,
and look at the data, and
to educate, and sometimes
re-educate ourselves.
I can't tell you
the number of times,
even when I look at the data,
sometimes with different cuts,
they surprise me,
because I'm not
used to thinking of some of
these populations in the way
that the data reveal themselves.
Quite apart from looking at
the growing proportion of Asian
Americans and their share
of the immigrant population,
other kinds of data that
people usually use to say,
pay attention to
Asian Americans,
look at their purchasing power.
So Asian Americans
by 2020 are going
to be worth over $1 trillion
in terms of purchasing power,
on par with the African
American and Latino populations
in the US that are much larger.
If you look at
wealth generation,
Asian Americans are
expected to reach parity
with the non-Hispanic white
population in about 20
to 30 years.
And in business formation,
you see a pretty significant
increase in the number
of businesses that
are owned by Asian Americans.
So for all these reasons,
we can say that we're
growing in importance.
We're becoming more visible.
We're increasing in terms
of purchasing power, wealth,
et cetera.
So what's the problem, right?
Asian Americans seem to
be doing pretty well.
There does not seem
to be a problem.
Well, one problem is
the model minority myth,
which many of you may
have heard, right?
What I've shown you so far
are aggregate statistics
about the Asian American
community, including on wealth,
but if I showed you
something on education,
it would show you that
Asian Americans actually
have higher levels of
educational attainment
than the non-Hispanic
white population.
But when you take
that aggregated data
at the level of racial group,
it often masks disparities.
And there are
significant disparities
within the Asian category.
This is what people call
"data disaggregation," right?
Whenever you are
able to get access
to more fine-grained data, you
can make better inferences.
This should be
pretty self-evident
when you're talking
about scientific analysis
or social scientific analysis.
But as I'll say
in a second, it's
actually become
controversial recently.
But without data, we
cannot make our case.
So if you look at
educational attainment,
even though Asians on
average have the highest
levels of educational
attainment in the country,
there are huge
differences, right?
So at the top you have
Taiwanese and Indian Americans
that have the highest levels
of those with a bachelor's
degree and higher.
By the way, Mongolian Americans
have pretty high levels
of educational attainment.
And at the lower
end of the spectrum,
you have what have tended
to be predominantly
refugee populations, right?
Vietnamese, Burmese,
Hmong, Cambodian, Laotian,
and Bhutanese.
And the gap is just
enormous, right?
From the low teens to
about 3/4 of the population
that has a bachelor's
degree or higher.
Within the Pacific
Islander population,
there are less differences,
but you'll notice
the scale has changed a bit.
But the highest level
of bachelor's degree
attainment or higher is among
the Melanesian population,
which is about one in five
have a bachelor's degree, which
is on the lower
end of that scale
when you're talking about Asian
Americans and Pacific Islanders
together.
This is why data
disaggregation is so vital.
It's not just on
educational attainment.
If you look at limited English
proficiency, huge differences
between Indians,
and Sri Lankans,
and Pakistanis who do
not have as high language
needs versus Bhutanese, Burmese,
Vietnamese, Thai, et cetera,
that have significant needs
for translation and other kinds
of assistance when it comes
to dealing with officials,
dealing with agencies that
communicate predominantly
in English.
Now, we know that disaggregation
is important, and yet,
recently--
we've seen this in Rhode Island.
This is something that is
coming up in Massachusetts.
There was a controversy that
raged in California last year.
We're seeing this as a
controversy coming up
in Minnesota, where you've
had Asian American populations
that for decades have
been pushing for data
disaggregation, so they can
get a better sense if you're
talking about
language assistance
in terms of schools
dealing with parents.
If you're talking about
language assistance
when it comes to
hospitals and what
they need to provide
at the local level.
Data disaggregation has
been central to advancing
an Asian American agenda.
What we found recently is
a predominantly Chinese
immigrant population
that are mobilized,
largely through WeChat
and other online networks,
have had a very skewed
perspective of what
data disaggregation means.
And this arose out of
California a couple of years
ago where someone
convinced a bunch of people
that if you're collecting
this disaggregated data,
it meant that
you're going to have
quotas on Chinese people
in Berkeley and Harvard.
That is not the intent
nor the consequence
of all of these data
disaggregation pushes.
These data disaggregation pushes
were intended, and designed,
and implemented to help
disadvantaged populations
like the Hmong in
Central Valley, right?
Or the Cambodian
population in Long Beach.
But somehow this
has gotten sucked
into the affirmative
action debate,
and that's something we can
talk about later as well.
And we've had a very
skewed perspective.
So this is from a
protest in Rhode Island.
And we've seen this elsewhere.
And what's remarkable
about these protests
is the participants are very
convinced of their cause
without necessarily
understanding what
data disaggregation is about.
And I find it a
little sad, actually--
and I'll editorialize
a little bit here--
to bring little children
holding up signs saying,
I am American and don't
discriminate against me, right?
Whereas the bill actually
does nothing of the sort.
I'll just point to that teenager
who looks very uncomfortable
and the little
girl in a stroller.
Some people say
that this is great.
This is a sign of activism.
This is a sign of the Asian
American community empowering
themselves.
I think we need to re-examine
what empowerment means.
It's not just
simply speaking up.
It's actually having
a sense of justice
and knowing where we fit
into the racial order.
I know that some of these
things will be controversial,
and I invite conversation
and discussion.
So the lessons on data--
one thing it does
say to us, though,
when we look at data
disaggregation is that we
cannot just assume that just
because our communities have
been fighting for this--
we've been fighting for
this for over 30 years
to try to get government
agencies to get
more fine-grained
data so we can have
more effective public policy.
Just because we've
been fighting for it
and convincing other people does
not mean that the work is done.
In fact, after all these
policy victories have occurred,
now we're seeing a
new set of challenges.
And we need to reach out.
Both internally, within the
Asian American Pacific Islander
population, but also externally
to continually make the case.
We can't just assume that
once we've said something
that people get it.
And on this, I'll
quote Judge Mike Kwan,
who's a Chinese American in
Utah, who I think put it best
in terms of some of
the recent controversy.
Because many of the activists
have been pushing hard
against legislators, against
people like Jennifer, and I,
and others saying that we're
out to, kind of, exclude Asians.
That what we're
doing will introduce
a new Chinese Exclusion
Act or Japanese internment.
There are people who
have been advocating
for data disaggregation
who've been called Nazis
or employing Nazi tactics.
Now, I'm not just
using hyperbole here.
These are verbatim
things that you
will hear on WeChat, on
Twitter, and elsewhere.
And I think Judge
Mike Kwan put it best.
"Truth is the greatest
casualty of the current times.
Don't like the facts?
Just call them fake
and ignore them.
Don't like the messenger?
Call them stupid liars.
The simple truth that every
community advocate who has ever
sought funding for
the community knows
is that data equals dollars.
If you cannot demonstrate
through data that a particular
group is in need of assistance,
they won't get any."
So I'll just leave those
words, and I'm, again,
happy to talk about
it more in the Q&A.
So, one, when we talk about
the story of Asian Americans'
growing numbers and
increasing in their wealth,
it masks this enormous
set of disparities
within the population.
The other problem is of
low civic engagement.
We generally do not vote
in nearly the same numbers
as the rest of the population,
and it goes noticed, right?
So if we don't participate,
our economic contributions
are not recognized, we are
seen as a perpetual foreigner,
and our leadership and
talent hit a bamboo ceiling.
So, first, when it comes to
our economic contributions,
it's not just today
that people recognize
that Asian Americans are vital
to our country's economy.
So these are photos
from California.
One is of a Chinese miner around
the time of the gold rush,
and the other is
of Chinese rail--
Chinese immigrants who
are railroad workers who
are essential to
building the Western end
of the transcontinental
railroad.
The transcontinental
railroad and the benefits
to the American
economy do not become
realized without
the contribution
of Asian immigrants, right?
So we're so vital to
the economic history
of our country.
And, yet, when you look
at the official portrait
of the golden spike that
united the Western and Eastern
halves of the
transcontinental railroad,
there's not a single
Chinese immigrant in sight.
All right, so just because we
are involved in the economy,
that we might be vital to
certain sectors in the economy,
does not mean that we're
going to get that recognition
unless we're civically engaged.
There's also a whole
history of laws,
starting out in
California and then
spreading to the
rest of the country,
where Asian Americans
have been excluded,
including Japanese
Americans who are
so vital to the agricultural
sector in California.
California passed
an alien land law
excluding Japanese, Indian,
and other immigrants
from owning land.
And as we all know,
Japanese Americans
were interned in California
and other parts of the United
States because of their
so-called perceived security
threat.
But this is not just history.
Time and again we've seen that
when you have economic anxiety
and scapegoating, we've seen an
uptick in anti-Asian violence.
So you have an image there
from anti-Chinese riots
in Denver in 1880,
the Vincent Chin
murder that many
people, especially
within the Asian
American community,
recognize and commemorate,
and most recently
the brutal murder of Srinivas
Kuchibhotla in Kansas, which
the Asian American community
is still, we would argue,
not commemorating quite
with the same fervor
as we remember the
Vincent Chin incident.
In fact, if you look in 2017--
this slide is actually
based on incidents
just in the first
half of the year.
Some very prominent
incidents of hate crimes
against Asian Americans,
predominantly targeting
South Asians.
And it's not just in terms of
violence in society, right?
So this is a very
prominent individual
no longer in the White House.
I don't know if people remember
the context of this quote.
This was Steve Bannon when he
was the chief of Breitbart,
and speaking with then
candidate Donald Trump.
So this is in December 2015.
And when Trump was saying
that maybe not everyone
should be sent back--
that with some high-skilled
immigrants, college graduates,
they should remain
in the country.
And Bannon said,
well, "when 2/3 or 3/4
of CEOs in Silicon Valley are
from South Asia or from Asia--"
first of all, by the way,
that is totally false.
It's a minuscule fraction
of Silicon Valley CEOs
that are Asian American,
let alone South Asian.
But here's another
thing he says.
And I think we should
actually take this latter part
very seriously.
"A country is more
than an economy.
We're a civic society."
What Bannon means
by that is actually
an ethnic nationalist vision
of what a civic society means.
But there is this
larger problem.
If we're only seen as economic
actors and not civic actors,
it makes it very easy
for those in power
to exclude us from
the civic sphere.
And we're seeing that.
We're seeing that with
the RAISE Act, which
proposes to cut family visas.
Now, many Asian
Americans, including
Asian Americans that are
highly skilled might think,
you know what?
We're going to be--
we're going to be OK.
Because we have high
skills, and, therefore,
Asian immigration is not
going to be affected.
Well, over half of
Asian immigrants
coming to the United States on
legal permanent resident visas
come in through
family sponsorships.
So it is going to
affect us, including
those that have high skills.
Many of them depend on
bringing relatives over
to make a new life
in the United States.
Just recently we put out a
blog post in the AAPI Data,
and also created
infographics, showing
how the proposed
cuts to family visas
would affect
different populations.
And as you can see,
it would affect
close to a majority of most
detailed Asian origin groups,
including Indian Americans,
Chinese Americans, Japanese,
Filipinos, Pakistanis,
Bangladeshis, and Vietnamese.
All right, so this an issue
that is hot right now,
we have to be engaged in.
But it is rare, it is rare
to see Asian Americans out
in the streets.
There were a set
of actions that we
helped to catalyze last week,
but they were nowhere close
to the kinds of
actions that we've
seen on the Dream
Act, and other actions
that Latinos have done on
behalf of immigrant rights.
So we absolutely
need to speak up.
Participation is key.
It's key to building power.
It's key to fighting racism.
And quite honestly,
per Steve Bannon,
it is key to being
seen as American.
If we're not there
in the civic sphere,
people are not going to see us
as part of the body politic.
So we've got a
lot of work to do.
This is part of a speech that
Barack Obama gave in 2016.
And people generally were
in a celebratory mood,
including the president.
He said "the AAPI community is
the fastest growing minority
in America, but it's still--"
like, everyone is clapping,
you know, everyone's excited.
"Well, that's good
to cheer about,
but it's still significantly
underrepresented at the ballot
box.
In 2012 just 56% of
eligible AAPI voters
were registered to vote."
Now, the president wasn't just
saying that to be a downer.
It was a very realistic
sense of where we stand.
People know that
we're important,
people know that
we're growing fast,
but they also know that
we under-participate.
It's not a secret, right?
This is one of the
things you get with data.
People know, and especially
elected officials know
if you're a group
that participates,
and if you're a group
that not-- that doesn't.
And we've seen that.
We've seen that in voting data.
Asian Americans vote
at much lower rates
than non-Hispanic whites
and African Americans.
It is also true in registration.
So here's a different
look at the data.
And you see big differences
within the Asian category,
in terms of what
voting looks like
and what registration
looks like.
Indian Americans tend to
participate more than others.
Which is actually a
little bit surprising,
given that they are among
the most recently arrived
to the United States.
And we can talk more
in the Q&A about why
that might be the case.
Chinese Americans
have the lowest rates
of voter registration
and voter turnout.
But it's not just voting.
Asian Americans, as
you'll see just below--
just above the bottom there are
much less likely than others
to contact public officials.
They're also much less
likely to engage in boycotts.
And they're the least likely
to engage in protest activity.
So even though many of us,
including many Googlers,
might have been involved
in the various travel ban
protests that occurred
in January of this year--
even when it comes
to protest behavior
where so much of our
interests are at stake,
we are much less likely
to do so than the rest
of the population.
So to sum up, we need to
redefine Asian success.
Many of us just think
about economic success.
Well, first of all, maybe
even before economic success,
many of us are socialized
into thinking about GPA
and academic achievement.
And then maybe after
that, wealth generation.
But we need to redefine
success to not only mean
economic advancement, but
also political participation,
civic participation, and
philanthropic activity.
And the success not only
of our community, but also
larger society depends on it.
Fortunately, we can draw
upon the inspiration
of many Asian American
heroes and she-roes.
So, for example, Wong Kim
Ark in 1898 helps establish
the bedrock of birthright
citizenship that every
immigrant depends on, which
is that if your child is born
in the United States,
citizenship cannot be denied
to that child.
It an Asian American help
who helped establish that.
The first Asian American elected
to Congress, congressman Dalip
Singh Saund.
He had fought for the right
for Indians and Filipinos
to naturalize.
And within two years
of getting naturalized,
he runs as a judge.
And then when he first--
and then after becoming a
judge, he then runs for Congress
and becomes the first Asian
American elected to Congress.
So we can draw upon all these
inspiring stories, right?
It is rare now when people
get naturalized thinking,
you know what?
I'm going to vote.
In my next election, I'm
going to run for Judge,
and I'm going to
run for Congress.
But we should look
to those examples.
And we have heroes from all
of our different communities.
This is one of the
things many people think,
well, you know what, our
community is so diverse.
It's hopelessly diverse.
We can actually see
diversity as a strength.
Because every one of our groups
have these inspiring examples,
including Fred
Korematsu who fought
the constitutionality
of internment.
Or Larry Itliong who was as
important as Cesar Chavez
to the establishment
of United Farm Workers.
And, finally, we should
look for inspiration,
not only within our
community, but also
with other marginalized
communities, including
other people of color.
And I love this photo.
This is a photo of Martin
Luther King in Selma
wearing Hawaiian Leis, right?
And this was a
gift that was sent
by Reverend Akaka to
Martin Luther King
to show the solidarity
of Pacific Islanders
with African Americans.
And this solidarity
remains as vital today
as it did during the 1960s
civil rights movement.
It is important for us to
recognize that our faiths are
interlinked.
That if you talk about
Asian American empowerment,
it is fundamentally linked to
the empowerment of other groups
that are marginalized
in this society.
Thank you for your time
and I'll now switch it over
to Jennifer Lee, who'll talk
about the National Asian
American survey.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNIFER LEE: Thank
you, Karthick.
I love that he added
she-roes to the hero label.
Thank you, Amy for inviting us
and for organizing this event.
And thank you all
for being here.
For those who are
live streaming,
we really appreciate
the audience
and we'd love to
hear your feedback.
What I'm going to do
is switch gears a bit
and talk about the National
Asian American Survey,
and some of the data that's
come from the National Asian
American Survey.
And just to underscore
a few points,
it was funded by a
number of foundations
without which it would
not have launched.
So the National
Science Foundation
has been a strong contributor,
as has the Russell Sage
Foundation.
And our program director is
in the audience, [INAUDIBLE]..
And I wanted to thank her
personally for her help.
I wanted to talk--
start off by talking
about what makes the National
Asian American Survey unique.
If you read newspapers
and you see statistics,
you see oftentimes percentages
of what whites support policy--
what percentage
of white Americans
support a particular policy.
What percentage
African Americans
support a policy, or Latinos.
What you often see missing
is data on Asian Americans.
And so, what the National
Asian American does--
Survey does is help fill
the substantive void
to provide data
on Asian Americans
at the national level.
What's unique about the
Asian American Survey
is that rather than
focusing on just
a couple of Asian ethnic
groups, we choose ten.
So the sixth largest,
which are Asians,
Asian Indians, Chinese,
Filipinos, Koreans, Vietnamese,
Japanese.
We also include
Cambodian and Hmong.
And we also include,
for the first time,
Bangladeshis and Pakistanis,
who have never been included
in a national survey at all.
What's also unique about the
National Asian American Survey
is that we conducted the
survey in both English
and in an Asian ethnic language.
And why that's important,
as Karthick mentioned,
2/3 of the Asian American
population is foreign born.
And many have-- are limited in
English language proficiency.
The problem is that
a lot of surveys
that have been conducted
in the past that
have focused on Asian Americans
were only available in English.
What that does is
then bias the results
to those who are English
fluent and typically younger.
And so we actually
had the survey
translated in a number
of different languages.
So let me begin by talking
about some of the problems
that Asian Americans face.
As Karthick says, some of the
rhetoric and some of the images
of Asian Americans is that
we are a highly educated--
uniformly highly educated
group, a high achieving group
with high median household
incomes, or highly employed.
We have high
self-employment rates.
That we're doing just fine.
We're assimilating just
fine, and on the way
to becoming white, or at
least honorary whites.
So that is some of the
dominant narrative, right?
And so what are
some of the problems
that Asian Americans face?
So we asked this question.
And so, at the top
of the list was
affordability of college,
the cost of medical care,
the cost of elderly care.
And as you can see,
a number of problems
that Asian American respondents
explained are problems.
And in the actual--
in our survey data, we have
it broken down by ethnic group
if you're interested.
I wanted to point to a
particular slide, which
is bullying.
So bullying apparently is a
particularly strong problem
among some Asian ethnic groups.
If you look at the
Hmong, for instance,
46% of Hmong Americans
have listed bullying
as a very serious problem.
And it's Hmong, Pakistani,
Indian, Bangladeshi.
What's the pattern here?
One of the things we're
seeing in our data
is this divergence
of experiences
between South Asians
on the one hand
and East Asians on the other.
So it's not as though Chinese,
Koreans, and Japanese don't
experience bullying, but they're
not experiencing it nearly
at the same rate as
South Asian Americans.
And this gets to another
point that Karthick and I
found in our data
that we, actually, we
wrote about in an op-ed,
which is that when
we talk about Asian Americans,
often times Americans, not only
white Americans, black
Americans, Latino Americans,
but also Asian
Americans seem to have
an idea of what Asian American
is or who an Asian American is.
And oftentimes we're thinking
about East Asians exclusively.
I mean, just to look
at this audience is
kind of interesting
because Karthick
and I were remarking that
this is a talk about Asian
Americans, but even this
audience, the live audience,
is predominantly East Asian.
So there's something in the way
we conceive of Asian Americans.
There is something
in the way that we're
behaving that is
creating this division
and excluding South
Asians from the fold.
Why that's important is because
when we talk about experiences
with discrimination,
with bullying,
we're selecting a
particular narrative
and excluding certain groups.
On that point, I wanted to
talk about some experience
with discrimination that
have come up in our survey.
So the first is with police.
Again, what we see is a
different set of experiences
between Cambodian, Indian,
Hmong, Pakistanis who are South
Asians versus Koreans,
Chinese, Vietnamese.
That South Asians are
more likely to have
had negative experiences with
the police than East Asians.
If we look at the
question of whether anyone
has felt that they've been
unfairly denied a promotion,
we see a different
pattern emerging.
We see that among Asian
Americans, more generally,
14% attest that they feel like
they've been unfairly denied
a promotion.
But if you look at the groups
who respond even more highly,
it's Filipinos and Indians.
And why this is interesting
is that these groups
tend to be more
likely represented
as white collar professionals.
And so, is it
possible that those
who are more likely to
be in mixed settings,
in professional
settings, are more
likely to experience the
bamboo ceiling, so to speak?
And so this is something that
Karthick and I are working on.
Trying to understand, not
only the figures about who
feels they've been
unfairly denied,
but what are some of
the mechanisms that
are suppressing advancement
among Asian Americans?
And just to give
you a statistic,
among Asian American
college educated
males, when you hold
all things constant,
like where they went to school,
their major, where they live,
all sorts of-- a
host of factors,
they make 8% less
than white males who
are comparable on every scale.
Asian American women earn
as much as white women,
but they're less likely to
be in supervisory positions.
So they are less
likely to be promoted
to the managerial ranks.
So even when you attain
the right degrees,
even if you go to
the right school,
even if you have the
right experience, that,
for some reason, we're not doing
as well in the labor market
as we should.
Another thing that came up,
about 1/5 of Asian Americans
report that they receive
poor service in restaurants
and stores.
And again, you see an
interesting pattern
where Filipino, Hmong,
Indian, Bangladeshi
are more likely to
report this as a problem
than other Asian ethnic groups.
This, I think, many
of us have experienced
at one point in our lives.
For how many have you
received a comment
that people are either
surprised that you
speak English or surprised
that you speak English well?
So that is at least half here.
And you are Googlers, so
I presume that all of you
are fluent in English.
But, so, about 30% of
Asian American respondents
report that people act as
if they don't speak English.
And, again, you see
variation among the groups.
And this is a theme
that Karthick and I
will continue to speak about.
That on the whole, there
is tremendous diversity
among Asian Americans.
Yet, at the same time, there's
a similar pattern that emerges.
This is another thing
that I think many of us
have experienced, that you've
had your name mispronounced.
How many people have had
their name mispronounced
at some point in their lives?
So much so that I'll just
draw my own experience.
So my first name
is a Korean name.
It's [? Geyaun. ?] When
I became naturalized--
I don't even know if
Karthick knows this story.
When I became naturalized,
I had the choice
to add a middle name.
And so, I added Jennifer because
I was actually very tired
of having to say my first name
over and over again, or have
a substitute teacher come in,
and stop at my name, and pause.
Yet, if you think
about [? Geyaun ?]
it's not phonetically difficult.
And if you think
about it, we work
really hard to say
white ethnic names that
seem impossible to pronounce.
Yet for some reason
Asian ethnic names
are difficult to pronounce,
and people don't even try.
So, again, about 2/3
of Asian Americans
have experienced
this, particularly
Indians and Japanese.
This is another
thing that I suspect
many people in the
audience have experienced.
That people assume
because you're Asian,
you're good at math and science.
And so, I'd love to see a
show of hands of how many have
experienced this?
So, math and science are not
my particular forte, actually.
But I think most
people assume that I'm
good at math and science.
And people assume
that most Asians
are good at math and science.
Again, are perceptions.
And this might seem like
a positive stereotype
in some ways.
But one of the things
that Karthick and I
will write about, and
are writing about,
is that in some
ways, when you're
perceived to be so good at
technical skills, oftentimes
you're also perceived
to lack social skills,
or so-called soft
skills, that are needed
for leadership positions.
I wanted to go on and
talk a little bit more
about some of the opinion data.
So, oftentimes, Asian
Americans are perceived
as just caring about education.
Just getting into
the top schools.
But we're actually--
we have strong opinions
about public policies.
We're very strongly
against a Muslim ban.
And this is uniform
across groups.
About 2/3 of Asian Americans
are against a Muslim ban
that Trump has proposed.
Asian Indians evinced the
strongest opposition, almost
80% are against the Muslim ban.
We also strongly
and somewhat agree
that undocumented
immigrants should
have a pathway to citizenship.
That on the question of
undocumented immigrants, Asian
Americans agree that
there should be a pathway.
And our numbers are
very much in line
with those of white, black,
and Latino Americans.
Latino is a little
bit higher, actually.
This is another
slide that I thought
was very important
to point out, which
is that one of the things
that oftentimes gets enmeshed
in the debate about
affirmative action
is this idea that
Asian Americans only
care about themselves.
But one of the things we
find is that 72% strongly
support that the
government do more
to ensure equal rights between
black and white Americans.
This is an incredibly
high percentage.
And in some ways, it
even surprised me.
But I think this underscores
the point that we
are a multifaceted group.
That we care more than
just about getting
in the right colleges.
We care more than about
just getting the right jobs.
That we have very
much, very diverse
set of interests that are
not oftentimes profiled
in the media.
We're also very committed
to climate change
and environmental issues,
again, which is something
that the media does
not particularly
point out about our population.
Since I'm running out of time,
actually, this is perfect,
I'm going to hand it
back over to Karthick
who's going to talk about
the presidential vote choice.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN: And I'll
just say this very quickly.
Thank you, Jennifer.
We also have data on how
Asian Americans voted.
And, in fact, it's different
from what the exit polls show,
which were not done
in Asian languages.
Those were only done
in English and Spanish.
And we-- well, I'll get
to that in a second.
One thing about 2016 is
that it was a record setting
year for Asian Americans.
So we doubled our
normal increase
in terms of the increase
in Asian American voters
per presidential cycle.
In terms of how Asian Americans
voted, across the board,
Asian Americans favored
Clinton over Trump,
although there are some
significant differences.
Before we surveyed
Bangladeshis and Pakistanis,
it used to be that
Indian Americans were
among the bluest
of Asian Americans,
but maybe not surprisingly
given the role
of anti-Muslim rhetoric
in the election this year,
and given the fact that
Bangladeshi and Pakistani
Americans are a predominantly
Muslim population here,
that they showed the highest
level of support for Clinton.
Still, we have a fair
number of Asian Americans
who do not identify as either
Democrat or Republican,
although that's a
three-point partisan scale.
What political
scientists do is they
take people who say that they're
independent and ask them,
are you closer to the Republican
Party or the Democratic Party?
Overall, we see that
the Democratic Party
has a pretty strong
advantage, except among
Vietnamese Chinese, and
Cambodian Americans.
And among Chinese
Americans, actually, we're
seeing a drift, a
shift perhaps related
to some of the
conservative activism
that we've seen in
the last few years.
But potentially other
broader demographic trends
in which we're seeing
a rightward shift
among Chinese American voters.
And then finally, even though
Asian Americans are growing
and they're getting
more active, we've
had a record increase in
Asian American voters,
Asian Americans
are still much less
likely to be
contacted by parties.
And this sets up a
bit of a catch-22.
Parties are more
likely to contact
those that are registered
with the party,
consistently vote, and have
strong party identification.
Asian Americans tend
to index low on that
compared to the non-Hispanic
white and black populations.
But party contact itself also
increases all of those things.
All right, so just like you have
a virtuous cycle among whites
and African Americans where more
contact means more engagement,
Asian Americans
seem, so far, to be
trapped in a vicious cycle of
less contact, less engagement,
less subsequent contact.
And we need to find out ways
to break out of this cycle.
So I'll end with that.
And if Jennifer can join me
up here, well take some Q&A.
AMY: Great, thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
So we have two mics in the
audience for live questions.
JENNIFER LEE: This is Kaya.
AMY: And so, if you have
a question, go ahead
and stand up and ask.
But, you know,
the first question
that I kind of want
to get a sense of
is, you know, you mentioned that
you believe the model minority
myth is one of the
biggest challenges facing
our community.
What are some ways we can
think about combating it?
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN:
So I'm going to-- someone
actually tweeted at me.
Because I tweeted that we
were speaking of Google, and--
so this gets to the model
minority thing, this something
the Google can do.
So this is a--
this is like civic
engagement live in action.
Jason Fong, who
by the way started
blogging when he
was a high schooler
and he's a freshman
at Wesley now.
And he says,
Professor, please tell
Google that its definition
of Asian Americans
as being chiefly East
Asian is inaccurate.
If you guys look up Asian
American definition in Google,
it uses something, I don't
know from what dictionary,
but it says--
actually, I'll read
this out right now.
And it says, "an American
who is of Asian--"
and then in parentheses
"(chiefly East Asian) descent."
This is important because if you
look at the demographic data,
less than 40% of Asian American
population now is East Asian.
The reason I bring this up is
that our model minority myth
but also in our notion of who is
Asian is kind of frozen in time
and very, very stereotypical.
And it-- it hurts us.
Even though we think it
might be a compliment
to be seen as good
in math and science,
it means that people
who have creative talent
are less likely to have
that talent recognized.
And so, I think
what can be done--
part of it is changing
even the stories
we tell ourselves
as Asian Americans,
but also continuingly
showing our complexity
and not shying away from showing
those parts of ourselves that
are not in line with
that model minority myth.
I don't know, Jennifer
if you have something--
JENNIFER LEE: I would say one
other thing is that Karthick
and I wrote about when--
there was a shooting
of Kuchibhotla,
one of the things
we both noticed
was that there wasn't the
outcry among Asian Americans
as there was with Vincent Chin.
And Vincent Chin's, his
murder was 35 years ago.
And still, every
year that comes up.
And that becomes heralded as
an issue that in some ways
unifies us.
That didn't happen
most recently.
And it hasn't been
happening when
it comes to South Asians
who are experiencing--
who are much more
likely to experience
hate crimes and discrimination.
And here I would think that
we are much stronger when
we unify across ethnic groups.
We experience similar
types of discrimination.
And how much more
powerful we can
be if we decide, at
least among ourselves
and also collectively, show a
stronger collective unifying
identity that Asian American
includes not only East Asian,
but also South Asian who are
demographically, actually,
becoming a larger
part of our population
as Karthick mentioned.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN: Yeah,
one quick thing, if I may, Amy.
It's just a--
February, 2018, let's see what
Google, other Silicon Valley
companies, and Asian Americans
throughout the country
can do to commemorate
that anniversary.
Because the effects of
that still reverberate.
So his widow had--
her visa status
was in jeopardy because her
sponsorship had "expired"
with her husband's death, right?
So we need to--
this stuff is so powerful.
And the fact that we are not
rising up and speaking up
actually makes it more
likely that policies
will get passed that
disadvantage our communities.
SPEAKER 1: I really appreciate
the themes coming out
of you sharing around
community and coming together
as a community.
But, you know, what
we're also seeing
are some very real nuances
in the data around opinions
of different ethnic groups.
So I'm curious around
your thoughts and ideas
for, you know, how
do we move forward
as a collective community, you
know, recognizing, as well,
the diversity that exists.
Like, the vast diversity.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN:
So I'll start,
and then, Jennifer, you can--
JENNIFER LEE: Yeah, you start.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN:
So one of the-- you
know, people who are not
Asian kind of get confused.
You're like, wait, you say
that you're-- you say that
you're Asian, but
then you also say,
we're very different and
don't lump us all together.
And it's like, it's hard.
How can you be one and
many at the same time?
And the academics in us
would say, it's complicated,
but we can't say that, right?
So part of it is contextual.
So, yes, there are vast
socioeconomic differences.
But when it comes
to public opinion,
on a bunch of
public opinion data,
Asian Americans-- so, for
example, on the Affordable Care
Act, on universal health
care, on the Muslim ban,
and a bunch of other issues,
are actually pretty unified.
So just because-- so data
disaggregation does not
mean that these groups
will never come together
on anything, but it's
only when you disaggregate
the data is you
can tell what are
the circumstances under
which this group is very
different from each other,
what are the circumstances
under which they're unified?
So we need to have an
evidence based approach
to this question, and
not something that's
just based on stereotyping.
JENNIFER LEE: I would also
say one other thing, which
is that if we look at
the Latino community,
there is enormous
diversity among Latinos.
There are Cubans,
there are Mexicans,
there are Guatemalans,
Salvadorans,
enormously different achievement
outcomes, enormously different
migration experiences.
Yet, as Latinos, they are
a powerful political force.
And so that's what,
I think, we're
missing as Asian Americans.
We-- just because
we identify as Asian
and we take an
inclusive approach,
does not mean that we
deny our ethnic origins,
or national origins,
but the power
that we have as
Asian Americans is
much stronger as a collective.
Just as Latino is much
stronger than Cuban.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
And I believe we
have a live question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hi.
Thank you for the talk.
I was just really curious
about the sample size
that you collected
to gather this data?
And how did you decide on the
questions that were prompted?
Like, if you were
bullied, which are you
leaning more towards,
Republican or a Democrat?
And all of the questions
that you mentioned.
So I'm just really curious with
the methodology a little bit
more.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN:
Excellent.
Yeah, so this is--
so the-- I think the overall
sample is little over 4,000
for Asian Americans.
JENNIFER LEE: I think 4,300.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN: 4,300.
There you go.
JENNIFER LEE: Yes.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN: We
tried to get at least 300
per group, just in terms
of the statistical power
that we need for most of
the kind of differences
that we see.
In terms of the
questions, it's layered.
Some of it is
repeating questions
that show up in other major
National Science funded
surveys, like the American
National Election Study
and the General Social Survey.
Some of it is also
questions that we've
asked in the past
based on conversations
with community organizations.
So the question
about bullying is
part of this larger set of
questions about the challenges
that people face for
themselves and their families.
And so we're repeated
some of those questions
to track it over time.
JENNIFER LEE: Yeah.
And I would say that
what's interesting
is that when you have
four people, four
principal investigators,
we all have-- we
come with different interests.
And the three of them are
actually political scientists
and I'm a sociologist.
And maybe that doesn't make
a huge difference to you,
but we have very
different ideas of what
are important questions.
And like Karthick
said, part of NAAS
was to fill the
substantive void.
People were not surveying
Asian Americans.
And so we had no idea
how Asian Americans
stood on certain issues.
So some of that is
just the questions
that were asked of
other Americans,
but were not asked
of Asian Americans.
And then other
questions were built
thinking about the unique
experiences and challenges
of Asian Americans.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
One thing I'll say, by the way,
is not only in this survey,
but in prior surveys,
both that NAAS
has done but also
AAPI Data has done,
we've uncovered other issues.
Environmentalism is one of them.
Most people when they think
about environmentalist
don't think of Asian
Americans, but we actually
index much higher
than US average
when it comes to
pro-environment attitudes.
Gun control.
We have some of the
strongest attitudes that
are pro-gun control, but
Asian Americans rarely
get talked about.
Like, after Vegas,
how many people
were asking, where do Asian
Americans stand, right?
But the fact that
we have this data
hopefully can help
change that narrative so
that we are written into the
stories of what Americans
think about gun violence
and gun control.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
for that question.
I'd love to hear if there are
notable differences, talking
about survey data, between
the first generation
and second generation that
emerged from the NAAS data?
If you saw any patterns there?
You know, do young
Asian American adults
differ in their views
on policy issues,
than say, you know, compared
to older Asian American adults.
JENNIFER LEE: Actually
I'll start off with that.
I think-- I'm so glad you asked
that question because we have
so much more data than
we're able to present
in this short period.
And if you're
interested, you can
look at the link
that's listed below.
One of the most
interesting things
is that if you break down the
data by generational status,
so first generation, meaning
born in a different country,
second generation, born here.
And also if you break
it down by age, so 25
and under versus 25 and up,
the younger second generation
are incredibly more progressive
on all of these issues.
So Asian Americans are much
more progressive on all
of the issues that
we discussed, which
is oftentimes a misperception.
But if you look at
the 25 and under,
and if you look at
the second generation,
they're actually
even more progressive
about the Muslim ban.
They oppose it more strongly.
They're more likely to support
a pathway to citizenship.
climate control, gun control,
all of the issues.
It's really actually quite--
it feeds me with a sense
of optimism about where
we're going as a community.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN: Yeah,
the one caveat I would say,
though, is when it
comes to participation--
JENNIFER LEE: Yes.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN: --so all
you Asian American millennials
in the room--
JENNIFER LEE: Yes.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN:
--and online,
we need to step up
our game, right?
JENNIFER LEE: Yes.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN:
'Cause it used to be--
so when we were
looking at this puzzle,
Asian Americans
on average tending
to have among the highest levels
of educational attainment,
but the lowest levels of
political participation.
That's a huge puzzle.
The political science
and sociology literature
would not predict that.
So what accounts for that?
Generally we found
immigration related factors.
Turns out that most people got
their college degrees in Asia.
They were not socialized into
politics in the same way.
They don't understand
the party system.
the issues.
They're not as engaged.
So that should mean that
the people born here,
who went to college
here, who are progressive
in all of these-- or
even maybe they're
conservative on a bunch-- they
have strong opinions on issues,
they should be engaged.
And again, Asian
American millennials,
Asian American native
born have among the lowest
rates of political and
civic participation.
That really concerns me.
If we think about what--
especially in a state
like California.
If you look at the
future of California,
and especially its professional
upper middle class population,
it's more and more going
to be Asian American.
What are we doing to hold up
our end of the civic commitment
to the state of California, to
the neighborhoods we live in,
and to our country?
I think it's a big question.
It's a big challenge.
And it's something
hopefully that all of us
can have a role in helping
to shape the future.
SPEAKER 1: I certainly hope so.
So we'll take one
more live question.
And then I want to be
respectful of everyone's time.
So I know we're a
couple minutes over,
but I want to give space
for this one last question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you both for
coming today and sharing
all of this illuminating
information.
Related to the last
question, instead
of just being
participants in terms of,
like, accepting this
information and, kind of,
letting it sink in, what
are two or three actions
that we can take to all
be part of that change
that you've mentioned today?
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN:
Well, I'll start.
JENNIFER LEE: Go
for it, Karthick.
Yeah.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
I mean, I-- this is hard work.
I mean, so we tried working
with different community
organizations through the
country to say, you know what?
Asian Americans are-- especially
on something like immigration,
not just on DACA and Dreamers,
but with the proposed
cuts to legal immigration that
the president just announced,
we should be up in arms.
We are so heavily
engaged in digital media,
we should be flooding
Twitter, Facebook, Instagram,
and Snapchat with what we think.
Many of us would not
be in this country
given the new kind of
qualifications they're talking
about under the RAISE Act.
So one of the
simple things we can
do-- so we had come up with
this hashtag called #AAPIaction.
And I would humbly suggest that
maybe not-- maybe that hashtag,
maybe something
else, but lets start
getting organized
digitally, because we're
so heavily indexed in terms
of digital participation.
But lets go beyond consumption
of, like, our YouTube stars,
and, like, questions
about who we are.
Like, these identity
questions are important,
but we have to be engaged
in digital and social media.
So that one easy thing I'll say.
Yeah.
JENNIFER LEE: Can I
interject right here?
I think one of the
things is you may
have seen a lot of hashtags
about Hollywood is so white.
And we are up in arms
about the lack of diversity
in Hollywood, in movies, and TV.
The lack of Asian
American representation.
If we could channel that energy
to some political causes,
as you mentioned, how
much stronger would we be?
How much more seriously
would we be taken?
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN: And
the last thing I would say
is let's see what we can
do on February, 2018.
I'm serious here.
That would be a good--
and we have several months
of lead time, right?
This is the anni--
one year anniversary
of Srinivas
Kuchibhotla's murder.
It was also the one
year anniversary
of the gentleman who helped
save his life, right?
So it also shows you the power
of cross-racial coalitions
and standing up for each other.
Let's see what we
can do, because I
think that will be
a good test of-- we
have enough lead
time to organize.
This is someone who
was an engineer,
so that should be
a cause that should
be near and dear to the heart
of engineers everywhere, right?
But even beyond engineers.
And this is something that all
the AAPIs should rally around,
because it shows you the power
of anti-immigrant rhetoric,
racist rhetoric, and nativism,
and how it can affect all of us
in very dangerous ways.
And it's important for us
to, not only commemorate,
but to make sure that things
like this don't happen again.
So I'll leave it at that,
as one potential test
to what our power could be,
both in terms of online activism
as well as offline.
SPEAKER 1: Well,
thank you so much,
both of you, for being here,
and thank you all for coming.
I appreciate your
attendance and engagement.
And thank you both.
JENNIFER LEE: Thank you, Amy.
KARTHICK RAMAKRISHNAN:
Good night, take care.
[APPLAUSE]